leaving the thunder okc was good enough
to give you some input into where you
wanted to go next
what is it about these guys what is it
about these this team that you said
phoenix i want phoenix it was a lot of
things willie green
my brother james jones we worked at the
union together
coach monte i played for him already but
the big reason
was the light-skinned guy right here
number one devin booker
devin booger he is a dog go get it
[Applause]
you got to make sure they're filming
right
you know the other night chris paul
calls you the oldest 24 year old he's
ever met
he says you are an old soul and you were
ready for this moment
how were you to borrow a word from your
coach how did you show so much poise
i mean that's that's what coach preaches
every day it's poised
um obviously he knows we're emotional
team
you know we get into it we get after it
you know so there's nights like that but
you know when we channel our energy the
right way we can make big things happen
like tonight you had
quite the game including taking another
shot to the nose you went without the
mask for most of the night tonight
what was it like for you to get up off
that floor knowing that this trophy
could be there at the end if you did i
mean this
this is what we set out to get tonight
um so we didn't want to go back to
phoenix without it
uh we didn't want to do a game seven we
wanted to do it here tonight
look i know what you're what robert
starver just said right
yeah he says this job is not done no not
at all
so how do you prepare for the nba finals
devin booker
i mean we sit back we get some rest um
we watch atlanta milwaukee
and just see who our next matchup is and
prepare that way well congrats to you
appreciate it congrats to the team
behind you congrats to the fans
back in phoenix they're just getting
started back to you
yo
scott
[Applause]
you